hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to SCP containment
breach I'm still on my game that I did
good with four thing I'm hereby
suggesting we extend the security
measures well this guy was smart he
wanted to kill it oh okay
three doors that would have been great
how would have been fantastic I guess
what's this another radio oh don't do
that don't do that don't don't do that
don't do not don't don't please
revision eyedrops oh those would be
useful I don't need I am yeah yeah damn
man oh oh yeah me in okay I don't need
you I don't know doesn't seem like
there's any code in here that I need
I don't think so I don't think so okay
I'm gonna drop that and no no I don't
think I need this and I don't think I
need this ooh I hear you I know you're
out there I know he's out there I know
he's like crawling through the walls or
something silly now why are those like
not fair
why won't this thing on the ground what
was the thing on the ground
ah what is that what is that hey what
are you what are you what are you are
you oh don't don't do or do I get I know
there's a mean that way I know it's a
way god get off my game no no use as
much as she's not the other guys guess
let's go Oh
oh no this place of this place Oh No
oh no no no oh oh no oh no oh no
where's that note I know I saw it's like
brighter now much others I know I think
I have to go the way of the note see if
new personal access code is 6 4 6 8
write this down
four four six eight
I start by tongue I saw my top of name
so I just pulled it paper out of there
so congratulations David
pixee congratulations David Pixy I'm
writing this code on the back of your
entry congratulations let's keep going
when you are not paying attention hi
what what oh no I'm not even in the
pocket dimension that's what that
thing's called it's called the parking
dimension that it's in then do too okay
I'm gonna go in here and a month what
the hell is happening is obviously
something bad
where is he I know he snapped my neck
nose in here before [ __ ] good boy go
away please
oh my god run please run run oh I know
this works out right
okay
toilet paper
let's see oh we got a new personal
access code
hey congratulations mr. Dibble rows row
okay I got ya do nine seven seven okay I
gotta get outta here huh
this is the next area where am i what I
died I didn't follow oh he's gonna get
me and bite my nipples off something I
don't know okay he's coming he's coming
I know he is
run don't go in the elevator just run
and just keep going and just leave this
place oh oh you're kidding me
oh you're can't be don't don't don't
pause through the wall
all right so here is this get the code
if I can get distinguish something okay
Oh what done what up whoa what the heck
is this
no thank you buddy on David
oh he's just porting me forward
he poured in me forward oh this is 106
oh it's the guy this is the guy with the
thing maybe I gotta close the door event
oh wait what am I supposed to do how do
i how do i how do I get in here how do I
get how do I get it done try later
where am i this is new this is new this
is new new
whoa oh is that the guy
femur breaker femur breaker I don't
think I want to do that sound
transmission on come on dad yura flunked
it yeah I'll try to yeah ah oh wait
there we go
what Wow I see it moving a little bit
favorite writer
oh that black thing
you disappeared
what is going on I'm so confused right
now
okay
what did I just do
did I just do what did I just do
what did I just do oh is that them down
there no wait yes No
Oh in that place oh I see I don't like
this at all
not even a little bit this is Bad News
Bears everything about this is bad
I've like never seen any of this before
so cool and so that at the same time
can't see you think I think I could
because there are lights but that's not
anything under the stairs nope never is
alright what I'll
Wow alright then I'm not sure what this
is I'm not even sure what se peeve is
supposed to be containing all right
there's nothing here was there I am
saying anything
I don't know how to get to uh this adore
maybe I don't know how to get to it I
don't know how to do it I don't know
what I'm doing I have no idea what I'm
doing
uh okay all right um okay maybe maybe
maybe maybe maybe baby maybe baby
I'm gonna go up see if maybe I need to
throw some different switches now or
something like that the music got a
little more dramatic that's for damn
sure
huh let me try listening it on the video
yeah
so broadly
Station one please
I don't know he said something about
like a broadcast station I'm not sure I
didn't quite catch it it's too much fuzz
I don't know what that was though I'm
guessing maybe I'm supposed to use my
like contextually sensitive I don't know
what to do here uh I just I I don't know
what that like door is here but no
buttons I don't know I don't know uh
uh-huh okay there's got to be something
to figure out because this is that's the
containment cell Wow then this is the
area here I had oh man like I've been
doing good so far with this save I don't
know if I was actually supposed to do
the femur breaker thing
oh maybe wait no hang on wait what if I
turn leave that off and go down home so
something about electromagnetic maybe
that's levitating the platform I don't
know I gotta try it
that's right oh that's right it's worth
trying yes it was that's this thing ah
ah see now now now now what do I do
about that huh where does that get me
where does where does that gets me
anybody want to help me out here anybody
does this do anything for me how how
does that help me
how how does that change something out
upstairs
and I still haven't seen scp-173
all right
okay I don't know maybe I did the femur
breaker too early I just don't know I'm
very confused I hope I don't
I hope I don't have to restart huh
that would be unfortunate after all this
traffic on how all right if I'm actually
I'm a lot of time so if you guys know
what I'm supposed to do in this area I
know I've never seen it but if you guys
know what to do please write in the
comments below also check out the
annotations for other videos that I've
done check out my reaction compilation
down below thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye